good morning good afternoon and good
evening ladies and gentlemen around the
world thank you for tuning in to the Tim
Ferriss show this episode is going to
touch a lot on creativity productivity
creating an identity for yourself
becoming a category of one and we will
explain what that means
but it's related to art and the art that
is your life so let's start with two
quotes the first is from Pablo Picasso
and it is every child is an artist the
problem is staying an artist when you
grow up and secondly if you hear a voice
within you say you cannot paint then by
all means paint and that voice will be
silenced too that is Vincent van Gogh
because most of you listening a lot of
you listening will not identify or view
yourselves as artists and perhaps after
this podcast you will think differently
but before we get to the guest an
incredible guest a tip and this is a pro
tip if you feel anxious if you have some
type of low-grade anxiety start making
your bed I know this is a crazy
recommendation it might sound ridiculous
there is a gentleman named Don de Pawnee
and he is a Hindu priest at one point I
was having a tremendous amount of
anxiety and he suggested start making
your bed at the very least when you then
come back at the end of the day or even
throughout the day you will have that
one piece of your life that you were
able to control completely and it will
seem orderly it will see him as it
should be
so this sounds nuts but believe me the
cascading effect can be pretty profound
if you have anxiety at the very least
perhaps you should consider start making
your bed in the morning doesn't have to
be fancy just has to look nice okay
moving on our guest ladies and gentlemen
is Mike Shinoda
if you don't know that name Mike is a
musician record producer and an artist
he is perhaps best known as the rapper
principal songwriter keyboardist rhythm
guitarist it's a long list and one of
the two vocalists of the rock band
Linkin Park if you want to consider it
rock band if you don't know what Linkin
Park
they've sold more than 60 million albums
worldwide and have won two Grammy Awards
Mike is also a solo rapper if you would
call it that in his side-project Fort
Minor
which I love to death it's amazing and
the lyrics are incredible
he's also provided artwork production
mixing for all of the projects that I
just mentioned and he has collaborated
with everyone from jay-z to Depeche Mode
and everyone in between it's a really
incredible career the story of how he
got started how they in some ways
accidentally became the phenomenon that
they are is fascinating and there are
many different take aways we get into
not just the broad philosophical
underpinnings but also advice for
beginning musicians or artists of any
type parallels between music and
publishing and and really any type of
creation along those lines some of his
daily rituals as well as for instance
how he and his band rehearse how he song
writes all of these things we really dig
into it so I hope you enjoy it it's
certainly visit the the sites in the
show notes and you can find all of those
including music for relief org which is
a non-profit founded by Linkin Park and
I've done work with them they've raised
millions of dollars for survivors of
multiple natural disasters around the
world you'll find all these in the show
notes so if you want to see the
transcript the show notes the links to
all the resources that are mentioned the
books and so on go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com forward slash podcast all
spelled out for our work week com
forward slash podcast and this podcast
is supported as always by you guys so
please if you enjoy this show if you'd
like me to do more of these shows they
take time they also take some money
please visit for our work week com
forward slash books for our work week
dot-com forward slash books where you
will find the Tim Ferriss book club
these are a handful of books that have
had a huge impact on my life and if you
click through it'll take you to Amazon
and that kicks back a little penny here
or there to keep this thing going so
without further ado I hope you enjoy and
thank you for listening
make this altitude I can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a question
no I must - any organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton mike shinoda
thanks for coming on the show hey thanks
for having me Tim it's been quite a few
years since we first met and I was very
amused to see on your Wikipedia page
that your bio shot is actually from
BlogWorld Expo when we first met and I
guess 2008 or so - ah so I'm very glad
that I was able to somehow indirectly
contribute to your Wikipedia page I
think that actually is a is a like a
replacement of I had said to the fans at
one point that I hated my the old P
picture that was there I was like you
guys seriously this is like the worst
picture of me it was from like 2003 and
I was in in mid-sentence with my eyes
half-closed like somebody had put it up
there as like to kind of mess with me I
think and it was horrible and so I asked
for I said somebody please like find a
great picture and replaces that that's
really funny so actually I'm gonna put
out a call to action to my fans right
now I hate my Wikipedia photo it is it
was taken of me at at LeWeb a speaking
engagement in Paris when I pulled an
all-nighter to get there and just look
like Al Pacino after a bender and really
really rough but we were initially put
in contact through Aaron Rey the Red
Baron so I just want to give him a nod
and a thank you for that but I've been
continually impressed as we've gotten to
know each other about how eclectic your
skill set is and and how you've come to
contribute not only to your own work but
to the work of so many other musicians
and also done art installations when
somebody asks you if they assume they
don't recognize you what you do how do
you answer that question I usually lie
first of all because if they don't know
what I do then I tend to like to keep
things
pretty you know mellow and especially
you know I live in LA and I live like on
the border of I live near Beverly Hills
but I think I'm technically in Beverly
Hills but I'm not also so I tend to do
like spend most of my time in more
low-key in the valley and stuff like
that we're in the Beverly Hills side you
walk around if you see paparazzi or you
see somebody you recognize from People
magazine that's not that surprising but
if that happens on the valley side it's
just a little bit more I think people
get a little more attention so I tend I
tend to like stray away from that I did
grow up however doing like the first
probably my first love was actually
drawing and painting and and I had
always thought I was going to grow up to
do that in fact we started the band I
started the band is like a hobby after
high school and I wasn't even very
serious about it until midway through
college and in college I was studying
Ellis tration at Art Center College of
Design it was very very serious school
it's a very rigorous curriculum and a
lot of the folks from there going to be
really great you know designers in Auto
and graphic design ad film and of course
illustration and you've done your own
art installations I remember seeing a
number of them there's one particular
piece that maybe you can remote remind
me the name of there were two women
there was a figure with a skull head and
it seemed to be composed of dollar signs
oh man I did a whole series I'm not sure
exactly which one that is but I did a
whole series a two-part show called
glorious excess mm-hmm and it was about
I was mostly inspired by the fact I felt
like I had a weird a unique perspective
on the idea of being a celebrity um we
started our I mean I started the ban as
a hobby on the weekends with a friend of
mine from high school and we we never
got into it with the intention of
becoming a signed band or a popular band
or anything like that it was just like
we love to do this where this is the
kind of music that we want to hear and
nobody's really making this specific you
know combination of elements mm-hmm and
all of the things that followed followed
and I found myself like one day looking
at it and going
realizing that you know they it never
really occurred to me there would be
people who would like fabricate a whole
I don't know music career with the
intention of becoming famous or becoming
like rich right cuz that wasn't on my
radar at all when we started we started
it because we love music that seemed
like yeah that's why you would start a
band right and then eventually you're
you know we're at the Grammys we're at
the MTV Awards and there are people
there who clearly are there because they
love to be famous they love to be
celebrities and so on even if they had
gotten into it originally because they
liked singing or whatever but now
they're clearly there for another reason
and this art shows you going back to the
art show I felt like I had I'm sitting
there in the middle of that like
literally just pulling out my phone and
taking pictures and video and stuff and
seeing this stuff and first-person and
just simply not relating to it mm-hmm
it's been a fascinating experience for
me to look at different success stories
and try to deconstruct the motivations
and also their focus on process or
outcome right and like you said there
some people are so focused on becoming
famous or becoming rich and of course
it's very small percentage succeed at
accomplishing that and if that's the
motivation it would seem to me at least
that they wouldn't actually enjoy the
process of creating the music or the
books or the art or whatever it is that
they choose as a medium and that's I
always found it sort of a juxtaposition
to your experience it seems like I've
heard the story you might be able to
confirm or deny this that you to the
band started it out and at least one of
the members decided we are going to be
the biggest rock band in the world from
the very outset but it doesn't sound
like that was or is the Lincoln Park
story what were the tipping points for
you guys I mean as the as the band came
together over time and you met people
not just in in high school but I guess
you met on at the when you were studying
art is that right that's right well I'd
say I mean it's a really interesting
time to be talking about this kind of
thing because we just put out a new
album called
the hunting party and and one of the
inspirations behind the hunting party
was rock right now is at a place where
it's very indie
Gault indeed Riven it's like everything
is if you compare it to 10 years ago or
15 years ago it's very it's a lot softer
it's a lot more dancey there's not a lot
of IDI genus to it or aggression I feel
right and so there was a day when I was
listening to the radio and I couldn't
hear anything anything to listen to you
and I was listening to all my music you
know services I just had a hard time
finding something that I that that kind
of filled that void for me so again it's
like whenever we have that feeling
whenever I get that feeling that's
usually a time when I go into the studio
and I start making whatever it is that I
feel like I'm missing and that's what
the new album is was inspired by but
it's also what the first album and the
original you know kind of idea of the
band was inspired by along the way I
think and not a lot has changed we've as
far as like the the philosophy of what
we're striving for and it doesn't you
know to your point it doesn't really
include like being the biggest because
if we wanted to be like the biggest band
in the universe I think we wouldn't make
an album like our new one our new ones
very aggressive very heavy we knew going
into it that we would be potentially
hurting our chances at getting on for
example getting on the radio right and
truth be told the radio is a great way
to promote your band and promote your
album and so on so if you know going
into it you're making something that's
not going to be effective in promotion
like you're making a decision that is
it's a creative decision not like for
example a career or Todaro or well
weight is a career aren't easy decision
but it's not a money decision right
right so going back though I think there
were definitely points when we were
getting started we met we were all kind
of friends from high school for the most
part I knew Brad I've known Brad our
guitars since we were out like 13 he was
good friends with my best friend Mark
who was the original singer on our band
Brad's roommate was our became our bass
player Dave my friend from college
became our DJ Joe Robb our drummer came
from neighboring high school and
eventually mark our other singer part we
parted ways because the the singing
thing was just you know getting on stage
like drove and Craig it was getting like
an ulcer he was so nervous and and it
turned out he was actually much more
talented at like the behind the scenes
stuff he ended up managing bands he
currently manages Ben
like Allison chains and he may manage
Deftones in Cypress Hill at one point so
yeah he's so that was what he was kind
of made for once we parted ways mark
though we found Chester through a mutual
friend and that was a that was a moment
where I only say that to say this so he
came into the band we did a whole bunch
more
you know showcases and shows and tried
to get signed and eventually got a
little bit of interest we got turned
down by every label indie and major
there was mm-hmm
but eventually we worked our way into
Warner Brothers we kind of convinced
them that we could like do almost like a
demo deal and make some stuff and if
they liked that they continue on and we
continue on with them is a demo deal
like a spec deal or you basically yeah
it's like a spec kind of situation you
created I mean let's put you in the
studio and depending on how it's going
it's a development thing it's something
that they don't do a lot of anymore
because they don't have the budget I
think like everything's so tight now
because sales album sales and are so
much smaller than they used to be they
tend not to develop artists in this way
anymore but with us to be honest there
wasn't a lot of a ton of developing to
do we kind of were developing on our own
and in the midst of it because of a
complicated relationship of like the guy
that had signed us with his boss and
that person with their boss and they
were all kind of new Chester our singer
was kind of new so there was a lot of
turmoil and they were trying to they
started to get nervous they started
imagining scenarios like well this bands
popular and that bands popular and they
tell us things like well you guys need a
gimmick you need we want to dress Joe in
a lab coat and the cowboy hat and chest
but you should like kick a shoe off at
every like ever every show like he was
stupid stupid record company stuff that
almost sounds like something out of a
movie like spinal tap
right it was absolutely true and these
were real suggestions like if you went
back I imagine that you'd say them to
somebody these days in the meek oh no I
was totally joking I assure you they
were not joking
we were sitting in the room and they
were literally ready to buy Joe a lab
coat and like beakers and put them in
front of his turntables
so yeah so so we got to that point and
we were making the album and we were
doing what we wanted to do and God about
halfway there and they tried to like you
know run away with the whole thing and
change everything they wanted to term
you know basically kick me out of the
band they're talking to Chester and
telling him you're the star you need we
need to do it this way and he's saying
but this is like Mike's been he's like
I've only been in the band for a few
months what do you want me to do like
this is I think it's I think it's great
yeah and then we talked we all talked as
a band and basically stood up to these
guys and said you can either you know
shelf us which effectively means they'd
be putting us in record label limbo for
the rest of our career we'd never put
out a record right or they can just
accept that this is who we are and let
us make the album we wanted to make
that's a ballsy move I mean it's it
panned out but like you said it's the
worst case scenario in that particular
case isn't that they say no and then
you're able to walk off freely with
everything that you had I'd imagine at
that point like you said you ran the
risk of being prevented from doing
things elsewhere if you walked I don't
if you had any sort of contractual
obligations at that point but it's been
it's been very challenging for me
working with television over the last
year and producing episodes having this
division at Turner effectively gets shut
down and having the content stuck in
this limbo space where yeah where you
can't free it it's just kind of in a
holding pen it's been super challenging
with when the record label realized that
they had something that could be hot or
that was becoming very hot what were the
indications did they take the music and
present it to a test audience did they
hear it internally and simply decide as
a group that they liked the sound and
therefore wanted to put some muscle
behind it what were the indications that
got them excited at that time especially
that was our first album came out at a
time when if we played a show we would
put out a mailing list that there at the
merchandise table right we'd have a
couple of we'd have us shirt our EP and
some stickers and we put out a mailing
list if you like the band put a you know
put your info down and we'll come back
and we'll contact you maybe we'll send
you some stuff maybe next time we play
we'll contact you people didn't even
have 50% of the people signed up with
their snail mail address because they
didn't have email yet so as you can
imagine like the mp3 wasn't a problem
for record labels yet right we signed at
a time when they were operating in a
very old-school manner and and it was
you know so when our album rather our
first single one step closer came out it
was you know it's what like it's like a
classic record label kind of attitude
like they throw it out there and see if
it sticks and if they catch some you
know some interest in it by the radio
stations then they they go a little
harder and they go a little harder it
was that there's no testing per se they
just kind of the only testing is like
we'll put it you know see if we can get
the djs and the programmers to put it on
the air and then see who's like what the
response isn't called whatever the other
thing is though it mean while we were
out touring really really hard playing
maybe five shows a week sometimes six we
were in an RV because we didn't we would
have been in a van mean we could we
didn't fit in a van gogh's there's six
of us with our gear we have a drum set
and a DJ rig that was the size of
refrigerator so we couldn't fit all of
our stuff in a van and I was driving
probably more than half the time it was
um you know you get offstage like you
played we may have played like 20
minutes get offstage clean up all of our
stuff in a hurry
put it all in the trailer and then draw
I would be driving you know half the
night to get to the next venue is pretty
pretty rough but you know I know that we
were boots on the ground like talking
the fans in person and and you know
managing our own the presentation of who
we are the introduction like this is
what our band is about we were doing
that face to face right so you were able
to sort of refine not only how you
communicate that defense but I would
imagine that helps you think through a
lot absolutely eventually well there was
a really funny story when we first
signed the label we told the guy that
was representing us we told him hey you
know can you get as many people as
possible from who might be working on
our stuff so man
mainly the rock department but whoever
at the label wants to come we'd like to
have a meeting at the out there you know
in their building and introduce
ourselves and he said yeah okay I'll set
that up keep in mind we were about
nineteen and we requested this meeting
with whoever everybody from the label
and they show up and they're roughly
there they're like between 25 and like
45 years old with like you know probably
an average of fifteen to twenty fifteen
years of experience in the music
industry okay and we go in you know
looking the way we did in our first
album me with probably like red hair and
Chester with the tattoos and like
piercings in his lip and whatever and we
go in with an outline of what we are
going to discuss with them like they're
gonna come in we're gonna tell them how
to do how to work our band let me tell
you will we're about let me tell you how
it goes with Linkin Park the instruction
the instruction manual it was so absurd
I couldn't believe like in retrospect I
can't believe they didn't just kick us
out of the building I think that it was
like humorous to some of them that this
band had the balls to just walk in and
like tell them how to do their job and
clearly we were way out of line but at
the same time you know I think they
admired the attitude of the group and by
the way they knew that we were very
sincere about this deep connection that
we were building with our with our fans
from day one how do you think about
putting yourself in the shoes of say a
new musician now so you mentioned the
the lab coach shenanigans and people
trying to get you to adopt a stick and
I've dealt with a lot of large companies
in a number of worlds when large groups
of those folks try to have creative
meetings they tend to sort of create a
camel which is you know a horse designed
by committee and it just ends up being
ridiculous and a lot of I would imagine
a lot of people succumb to that and
allow things to change to their band or
their book or whatever that they really
shouldn't to someone coming up now sort
of like the the Axl Rose getting off the
bus and welcome to the jungle right so
very sincere about let's say their music
but who wants to have a commercially
viable career what would what would your
advice to them be in this day and age I
would say for one thing you know there
are a lot of similarities whether you're
in in any creative medium whether you're
an author or film maker or musician
there are going to be situations that
are not the obvious ones where somebody
comes in and literally wants to just
like turn your thing into a you know
commercial obviously like like
watered-down commercial nightmare right
there's subtle it's it's really more
about those those are easy to pinpoint
and say okay that's absurd like lab
coats lab coat
you know scientist gimmick is absurd no
way right but it's more about like I
think it's more about the subtle ones
you know because even if they're not
trying to be manipulative a lot of times
your partners their priorities and their
their goals are not completely aligned
with yours you know and that doesn't
mean they're bad we have that's taken us
a long time to learn that you know as a
band because you know record labels get
such a bad reputation as it is just
being sleazy you know corrupt
organizations and you know they just
some degree they deserve that in to some
degree they don't you know not everybody
at a label is trying to scam all the
artists right
sometimes they're doing what they
genuinely think is best and they just
don't it's not in line with what the
artist thinks is best so that's those
are the things to look out for because
it can be very convincing and it can be
very subtle and it could not you know be
a grade-a mistake it could be like a
minor level mistake that over time you
know ten of those adds up to something
catastrophic so for example in a
situation like I think have we talked
before about that with books where an
editor like subtly you'll you'll be
writing something an editor might subtly
change a few words and then another pass
they subtly change a few more words and
all sudden you're looking at it and you
might go back and compare it to the the
draft before they ever got their hands
on it you go whoa they completely
changed the tone oh yeah of my chapter
or my story or what my
it was and so on and it happens over
time and at that point you've kind of
committed to a thing so that's yeah and
not not to digress too far but I just
brings to mind some of the lyrics from
one of your four minor songs which is
you know only doing print interviews via
email and that's not of course the that
that's not verbatim but I'm paraphrasing
right because the dealing with
journalists it's amazing how just a
single word replacement can change the
entire tone it can take you from saying
something that could be interpreted as
profound to completely absurd and stupid
with with one replacement so yeah yeah
you really have to have a fine-tuned
radar yeah context is everything I love
to do print I love to type my print
interviews if it's possible luckily
these days I feel like with social media
being as powerful as it is you know for
you and I you know if we're in a
situation where somebody prints
something that they've edited or changed
substantially we can go out there to the
fans and say hey you guys this was not
correct and yes is how it actually went
down this is how I feel which has to
happen once in a while but you know it's
again it's like I don't feel like
necessarily the people are being
deceitful it's just realizing that like
everybody's got their own agenda
yeah and different zine is not doing it
but like I'm even a music magazine is
not interviewing you because they love
music right they that's not necessary
that's not their their day-to-day is we
need ad dollars we need click-through
like whatever it is that's gonna get us
that and if you say if you have a forty
word sentence that chopped down to seven
is really titillating and interesting
and will definitely make people click
but it has nothing to do with anything
you ever you said in your interview it's
just clickbait they'll absolutely go for
that oh yeah because that's what they're
that's what their business is built on
yeah it's important when I'm talking to
people just getting ready or they're so
they have something taking off usually
it's a book coaching them on approach
this stuff but on the creative side of
things how is your songwriting process
changed over time
it has and and it wasn't different or is
it different for say Lincoln Park versus
for minor well our process is at the end
of the day it's pretty democratic mm-hmm
but it's rooted in an individual
inspiration and craftsmanship so when a
song starts usually I usually start most
of the songs it will sometimes it will
be a very fleshed out bed of music and
sometimes it'll just be a chord
progression on piano or guitar with some
vocals on it mm-hmm those two things are
very different from one another
can you explain just as a non musician
I'd love to hear why those are separate
so first of all just from the outside if
you don't know anything about recording
music it bears you know mentioning that
there's lots of ways to make music and a
lot of different genres I'd say first of
all a lot of different genres have
different approaches kind of built in
that are not similar to one another so
for example a producer in a rock for a
rock band is a person that comes in the
rock band is writing all of the music
and the lyrics the producer is kind of
helping them make decisions and help
sculpt the sound of the album and they
all work together but then but the
musicians in the band are really making
the song and the producers kind of their
coach right in hip-hop a producer does
the whole track all of the music
probably makes the hook the chorus makes
basically everything except for the rap
verses the rapper comes in and raps on
it and then the producer will make all
the mixing and finishing choices as well
so they do a lot more right in a - on
row than rock when we make an album it
generally takes about nine months from
start to finish to make the album mm-hmm
in contrast when we were making this
most when we're making the hunting party
next door to us was a world-renowned pop
singers session and this person came in
their producers were there for a few
days before they showed up and this
person showed up on day one and they
were there for about 15 minutes on day
two they showed up for less than 15
minutes and on day three they neglected
to show up at all and the song was
actually done and I was talking to their
people going like how is this even
possible
oh you know it's like we do this we do
that and I'm just like this is crazy you
know I I don't even
and as an art as a songwriter an artist
like I've definitely relate more to the
producers on that track than the person
who sings it but I don't I don't even if
I'd know if I'd be able to call myself
an artist personally if I was the one
just showing up for you know say 25
minutes and the song was done it's but
also because that's you know my interest
and my skill set and whatever that's
what I love to do so with all that said
you know I want to master as many
versions of making a song as I can so
every time we go into the studio I try
different approaches I've tried
approaches that come from you know folk
riding and rock and pop and hip hop and
whatever like whatever if it's something
I haven't tried before that sounds
interesting I might take that approach
in with with say hip hop specifically
and again I don't know any of these
people personally if you've collaborated
with say jay-z and if I'm curious in
your particular approach but much like
the sort of u2 story I've heard the Jay
Z is very famous for improvising and at
one point just to appease some record
executive pretended to be we're taking
notes but was actually improvising
lyrics in the studio what is your
approach with say hip hop specifically
how much of your time is spent writing
before hand versus improvising in the
studio and what is your writing process
look like
so if it's on the shorter and if the
song is kind of like let's say a song
appears and it's just magically great
and it's in a matter of a couple of
weeks it goes from the first notes
played to something that just sounds
awesome usually in those cases it's
because the melody and the the melody of
the music and the vocals have kind of
arrived at the same time or similar time
in a rap song or my buff of the Fort
Minor album the song where'd you go came
up that way it was like I was playing
the piano part I sang the chorus I said
that's that's what the song is I put a
drum beat to it I wrote the lyrics to it
and it was done mmm it was really just a
couple of weeks mm-hmm similarly on a
Lincoln Park song called breaking the
habit that one was I had like a beat
looping and then I was playing keyboard
over it and it was like a string thing
and and I added some I was singing
vocals over it
and the whole chorus was there the
melody of the verse was there and that
was like within an hour I knew there was
something to that song there are other
songs that we've done where they take a
lot of work I mean over the course of
nine months they might you know come
closer to sounding done and then B start
to get boring or you know start to have
materialized and then fall apart once
you add something there's a the new our
newest we're about to put out a single
called final masquerade and final
masquerade is a song that early on the
chorus the core the chords of the song
like the piano chords of the song and
the vocal were there from an early point
and and I and I knew listening to the
chorus of the song and the progression
and the verse that song is going to be
really good I really liked it at the
time though we were deciding the
arrangement of the song which means like
what other what do the other instruments
play what other instruments are on it
and one of the main things that was a
make-or-break element was the drum
pattern at the time when I wrote it
there were no drums and so I kept weak I
kept putting different things over it I
put programmed loops
I'd write live loops I kept trying all
these things on it faster and slower
tempos and all this stuff and it just
every time I put something on and I
could just tell it was kind of ruining
the song it just wasn't very good it was
a B or B+ and I knew this song had
potential to be really great so it did
take us a long time to just stumble upon
the right thing and it was a time when I
was in the studio with our drummer Rob
and I had already kind of picked the
tempo and I had said what if we do like
a halftime kind of almost like a more of
a hip-hop or classic rock like groove
drum loop type of thing and I don't
remember what the reference points might
have been or whatever but the main thing
was that we just you know Rob I said
just play and as you play I'm gonna like
give you you know suggestions about
where the hits might be or whatever and
it immediately started coming together
it was like within a few minutes you
could tell like this is them this is the
best groove for this song it's it's
totally making this phone better what
activities outside of music have had the
greatest positive impact on your music
that are not directly musically related
and that's I'll leave that brah
that I'm just any activities books
inspirations well you know I mean you
know from our our conversations that I
love experimenting with you know new
toys new technology I love reading
I tend not to read a lot of fiction I've
read your books I love books like the
tipping point in blink etc as well one
book that I read that speaks to this the
answer of this question is a book called
category of one mm by Jo Callaway and
it's about you know finding ways to make
what you do stand out um got it
yeah really nice it's a really nice book
there's a lot of great information in
there and one of the things that he
stresses is to benchmark what you do not
against your immediate peers or your
immediate competition even in your
category but compare it to things that
have nothing to do with your thing it
doesn't if you're a music maker there's
no reason you shouldn't say well can I
get great ideas from people who make
cars well who make shoes people make
apps people who make you know cooking
utensils whatever it may be
there you could have a great idea based
on something that's so foreign to your
thing so with that said like I've been
getting into things that that really
excite me but I don't know what how they
might you know inform what I do it may
be musical it may be kind of like the
visual aspect of how we present our
music but I love 3d printing and I most
recently got into AI just a freak
printing 3d o'the 3d printing yeah 3d
printing stuff um and I most recently my
wife actually got me for our anniversary
she got me like a camera camera drone
quadcopter it's by DJI it's called a
phantom Vision Plus mm-hmm and I've been
playing with that lately and that one's
actually really the connection for me is
just really easy it's like I love first
of all it's just really relaxing to do
but second I'm filming stuff with this
drone and I film like our film our
rehearsals or all film stuff as we
travel and stuff and that stuff is just
really it's just fun to do you've
constantly experimented with technology
that's part of the reason
and that we bonded and I thought that
BlogWorld Expo would be fun when we
initially met one thing that is
constantly on my mind is related to sort
of routines and habits of people who are
highly effective and you are I guess
right now as we speak getting ready to
is it rehearse or record we're
rehearsing right now we are going out on
a US tour with 30 Seconds to Mars and
AFI it's called the carnivores tour and
will be out from August to September
about six weeks got it so as we speak
it's about noon where you are what have
you found for yourself what can you do
to facilitate flow or sort of peak
performance for yourself whether that's
timing wise routines and rituals that
you have what have you discovered
personally one thing that I and I
believe that by the way kudos to you
because the one of the ideas from I
think your think that it was from the
4-hour workweek that occurred to me I
don't know if it was because it was
literally in the book or just the book
kind of inspired this thought just in a
broad sense looking at the things that
you do every day that actually are
making you better know whatever that
might mean mm-hmm
and the things that you need versus the
things you don't really need that could
be in your the way you handle your
emails it could be the the things that
you choose to read up on on your
computer or iPad or whatever before you
you know when you're not working um your
work flow during while you're working or
even like the things you choose to do
when you're not like is it making you
the way you eat is that affecting how
you you know feel during the day to do
your work or your creative stuff or have
fun and all of that I mean I found that
for myself personally I don't watch I
barely watch any TV i watch almost no TV
mm-hmm I do love movies I love going out
to movies I find it a more like
inspiring and rewarding experience than
television for some reason a lot of TV
you know barring the like more series
based stuff like I love Netflix as well
and I love like house of cards for the
same reason I love going to films you
know
and I stay away from I'm not getting
anything out of cooking shows and like
singing competitions and crap like that
like this especially that the reality
shows like really I feel like I've
totally wasted my my time at the end of
watching one or two of those so that's
like something for me that I just like I
started just removing from my my
schedule what another thing that I
always tell my wife that she's really
she's really working on and I I think a
lot of us have a tendency to like want
to respond to every email right and
expect responses from every email and
that's just unnecessary I feel everyone
I work with all my friends know that
given the opportunity to not respond to
an email I will take it I will delete it
if the answer is yes cool I would sooner
delete the email if your answer is gonna
be yes cool yeah if it's gonna be okay
or I hear you or whatever let's assume I
got this email and we're good I don't
unless I have something to say you know
right so if it's substantive I will
respond if it is subsidy spend if it if
you know I really feel like I have
something to offer my emails will be you
know they tend to be a little longer
they tend to have a lot of information
in them so you'll either get no email or
your get something a little long yeah
but I do that because I I don't like to
have like a hundred and fifty emails in
my inbox and I also don't think like
every time you send an email out I mean
I've seen you know you have we've all
seen threads where you've got five
people on the on the email and all of
them are responding okay cool yeah great
see you then it's like yeah I don't want
15 emails saying okay cool yeah it's
stressful it's very stressful yeah
now the the rehearsal itself that you're
gonna be going into what if you arrived
at as your format for rehearsal what
does that look like what's the template
every band will be every artist this is
totally different when it comes to her
saying I've heard that some groups just
get together and they just jam and just
play whatever artists is the opposite
we as you could probably imagine
we actually because we have six guys in
the band and everybody's pretty much got
you know families and other stuff going
on we set up rehearsals in a way that
you we start with just the most basic
people who are needed on certain tracks
so let's say we're right now we're
practicing up two new songs for this
upcoming tour that we haven't played in
front of people before mm-hmm and we'll
start those the first day of rehearsal
would be with just maybe our guitarist
and I and our baby sis and our drummer
might just be the four of us hmm and
then then we'll add Joe our DJ and then
we'll add Chester there's no reason for
Chester to come in and sing if the
music's not tight right so Chester gets
a day or even two days off from
rehearsal because of that it's it's
rougher on you know especially like the
instrumentalists it's more time but in
the big picture it's all a wash because
you know while Chester isn't in here
rehearsing on these days he's always
where he and I are always requested when
it comes to interviews right you know I
mean so so there's a balance a nice
balance of things you and whenever
somebody's not totally needed for
something we we kind of remove them from
the situation and also just just for
anybody for the techy people listening
one of the things we do that to make
those rehearsals extra focused we
actually have for everything tracked out
all of the instrumentals from the studio
recordings in the computer and we play
will unmute anybody who's not there so
if Chester's not here his voice will
actually still be coming through the
speakers because it's coming off the out
of the computer
mm-hmm so we use those strictly as
practice tracks and then of course we
don't use them live but we have those
around so that we know you know and we
can reference them to like oh hey you
know Brad I think that this note this
transition between the verse and the
chorus is actually these notes and we
can listen to the album version say oh
yeah that is what I played and then you
know Mike is wrong or Mike is yeah so
that's that's actually a part of our not
only our the way we rehearsed but the
way we we just operate on stage that as
technology has gotten as music
performance technology has gotten
more advanced it's actually allowed us
to be a better live band that's cool oh
yeah exactly where technology can
augment and not necessarily replace
performances I think that's something
that's often overlooked just for my own
personal curiosity what software do you
use for that type of tracking we use a
ton of different things on stage the
main things that I was talking about
about like the performance stuff is in
Ableton Live Ableton is great because
you can actually let's say if you
imagine like in your iTunes library or
whatever you've got a track you can play
it fast ordering wine mm-hmm Ableton you
actually can throw it in you can slow it
down speed it up pitch it if you wanted
to modulate the pitch you can mash it up
with other things and so on so you know
if we on some of the tracks like we have
a song called guilty all the same and
when we first started playing it we
wanted to practice it slower mmm so that
we could get tight and then move to get
it faster and faster so we actually just
turn the tempo down a little bit in the
computer playback slowly and and you
know 10 years ago this would have been
impossible or whatever the least taken
hours for the computer to process that
information and then you could do it
mm-hmm
now you do it like on the fly right
instantaneous you can do it in fact you
could do it as you're playing if you
wanted to hit a certain spot and then
slow down you can do that you can loop
spots you know if you want to practice
one spot over and over we actually have
a part during the set we do run some
stuff some backing tracks when we play
we try to be careful about that because
we always want to be a live band first
it's not a scenario where I think
everybody when they hear stuff like that
it's like do either wandering out there
vocals in the track and whatever we try
and stay away from all that generally
it's like percussive stuff and like be
loops and things like that again ten
years ago if we were doing that if we
were playing a song on stage and we had
that running if you got offbeat you'd be
screwed if you wanted to extend the part
you couldn't do it or if you want to
slow down you couldn't do it now we can
do all of those things on the fly if I
walk if I you know decide hey let's get
to this guitar solo let's play let's
have Brad play twice as long let's
haven't played five times as long any
night of the week any show we can do
that the Ableton rings a bell and I
could be mistaken
and I'll double-check this for people in
the show notes but I think that is also
the software that Ira Glass host of this
American Life uses when he's doing live
speeches because he wants to recreate
the feeling of one of his shows and so I
have an iPad up and he'll actually call
up different types of quotes and so
forth very cool yeah it's pretty it's
pretty amazing stuff we that's not the
only thing we use I mean just so that
it's clear like when I have a keyboard
rig and I - software-based I'm using a
bunch of stuff by Native Instruments I'm
using stuff by other makers Joe is
actually running his completely off of a
Windows tablet believe it or not his
real rig with the turntables and
everything is actually the brain of that
is actually a Windows tablet it's a
surface Wow that's so cool I love it I
tell you what I want to be cognizant of
your time and I know you have to
practice so I'd love to just do perhaps
a couple of rapid-fire questions if that
works for you and then I'll let you get
to making making your music so the the
first question is you mentioned movies
what are some of your favorite movies of
all time and that could include
documentaries non documentaries yeah I
love I think growing up I was really
into the like some darker stuff but
usually kind of plot driven I always
loved The Godfather movies I loved the
usual suspects mm-hmm I loved Fight Club
and 7 yeah actually saw Fight Club the
other day and I haven't seen it in a
number of years and it's still still
such a great like the story that the
writing is just so great yeah and then
on the other side like being an
illustrator I was into anime like I
loved Akira and I actually loved a bunch
of the Disney films wall-e is awesome
well I mean what an one thing that
always struck me about that is it's like
you've got a movie that's more than half
basically just score and visuals with no
dialogue
oh it's miserable an incredible feat
I've been researching screenplays
recently and working on one myself and
one of the recommendations I heard was
you should be able to turn off the sound
and follow the movie of course wall-e is
a perfect example of that so even in a
foreign film you should be able to
follow the plot or a lot of the major
plot points turning off the sound
Pixar's amazing with stories I'm
actually hoping to have the president
Pixar on this podcast as well to dig
into the stories because I think it's so
systematic and amazing how they approach
that have you seen Ninja Scroll before I
have I used to be so into Ninja Scroll
let's just Scrolls me anything yes
actually I think that our DJ Joe who
he's Joe has directed most of our videos
mm-hmm and he actually just directed a
movie called Maul which is coming out
soon on I think Paragon was the company
that picked it up and he just debuted at
this last week so it's coming pretty
hopefully pretty soon mhmmm AUL no it's
mal and yeah yeah it's about a bunch of
suburban kids they're all kind of
dysfunctional to some degree it's a very
it's an indie film in every respect and
it's these kids are very awkward all for
different reasons and basically they're
at the mall doing their thing and
there's a there's another kid who comes
in and opens fire in the mall and
shooting people and stuff so it's a
really interesting you know
uncomfortable an interesting film I had
a lot of fun you know doing we did some
score to it but actually going back to
the Ninja Scroll thing and all that Joe
is Princess Mononoke Ninja Scroll like
eat a lot of those types of movie those
movies in particular actually have
worked their way into some of his work
in the past oh no come in fact I fat in
fact like Princess Mononoke is one of
the one of the main inspirations behind
our video for in the end oh that's
amazing
I didn't know that Princess Mononoke is
for those people wondering you should
watch every movie made by miyazaki hayao
or I guess in English hiya Miyazaki and
if you ever go to Tokyo go to the Ghibli
Museum which is the Ghibli studios
Museum in the middle of you know Kushina
Park which is just amazing yeah what is
your favorite book or the book that
you've given most as a gift to other
people given most as a gift Wow
I think when the tipping point came out
I gave that book to a lot of people I
know that category of one was another
one that was really that I did pass
around a lot where most of the guys in
the band read blink as well yeah some
fascinating especially it's the other
tipping point really kind of put him on
the map
as an independent book writer and and I
do talk about I do talk about 4-hour
workweek up quite a bit Jim well I
appreciate that
yes thank you so thank you for that the
I would also feel remiss if I didn't
mention my wife's book by the way of
course which is although I'm not a big
fiction reader she wrote an amazing book
called learning not to drown which is
about a young girl whose brother is in
and out of prison how it was it was
inspired by my wife's actual you know
family growing up but it is fiction it's
not it's not a memoir it's about this
girl whose brothers you know actions
effectively like and devour her entire
you know social and family life and
she's forced to make decisions about who
she is and what she's going to do you
know as she finishes high school and
leaves the nest did you get you yeah
brie did she got onto you
yeah no no she did and I read fiction
before bed as a way of turning off my
problem-solving machine in my head that
tends to keep me awake so I'd recommend
people check it out for sure and I'll
link to that in the show notes as well
as people great so can people get it can
get a direct link when you hear the word
successful who's the first person who
comes to mind successful gosh I think of
Rick Rubin for some reason huh I think
that there's something about Rick mm-hmm
that we've worked with Rick on a number
of albums mm-hmm and he taught me a lot
about songwriting and producing but also
you know just life lessons he grew up
practicing Transcendental Meditation and
although I haven't really I've went to
this woman this teacher that he
recommended and I tried it out a little
bit and it's stuck and it didn't stick
like some people do it every day I do
not but meditation and and just like
focusing inward and turning off all the
noise mm-hmm it's something I do believe
in like especially if you're finding
that you're tightly wound at any moment
or in general you know it's a nice way
to just get yourself focused and I feel
like I make better decisions and I'm
more effective definitely when I'm
I have a clear head and I'm fresher yeah
you know it's I don't think I've ever
mentioned this before but Rick for those
people who don't know incredible music
producer you're gonna look up his is
discography on Wikipedia but first came
across his name actually on the the the
notes inside a sizzle here album when I
was just a little youngster but he's
also for those people who who've seen
the 99 problems video he's the guy with
the big beard in the car rick is
actually one of two people responsible
for getting me involved in meditation
regularly in the last few years
chase German Chase Jarvis a very you
know world-class photographer and Rick
are both the people kind of responsible
for in trying me to meditation and TM in
particular very cool if you could change
one thing about yourself what would it
be I guess the first thing that comes to
mind is something that I work on is not
expecting other people to do things the
way I would do them right or you know
not holding like my opinion in my way of
doing things even even like for you for
you and I being people that try like
spend a lot of time trying to be very
effective and and by the way balancing
that with things that we love to do as a
part of being well-rounded in whatever
and you know sometimes you hear things
from other people and you go well I why
are they that's so stupid why would they
do it that way it's like so backwards
and whatever and you feel like you want
to tell them I mean it would get to be
very preachy it's it's not I feel like
my to do right by my friends and family
and whatever that it's good to just
remember that everybody just kind of you
know to give everybody room to do their
own thing their own way and what I
choose to do is is my decision yeah for
sure that's something that it's a hard
one right I still do that I find like
one of the things this is actually a
funny one of my friends and I talk about
is like first of all just like simple
simple things like expecting people to
work harder on stuff mm-hmm because I
would like that's that's not that's not
very nice the other thing that's funny
is spelling mm-hmm in emails when I guys
like I said I'm gonna if I'm gonna write
an email I'm going to probably unless
it's like benign I'm gonna
right I'm gonna like write it I'm gonna
edit it I'm gonna look at it and there's
spellcheck and all this stuff and when I
get emails where people are just clearly
you know punching numbers on a phone and
we're punching letters on a phone and
it's it's a mess there's a part of my
brain maybe it's because my mom was a
stenographer yeah there's part of me
then my brain that's just like oh like
what an idiot yeah and I'd go no yeah
it's it's so true it's it's a real pet
peeve of mine as well so to all those
folks who are emailing people you want
to get a response from take the time
because not everyone sensitive to it but
I'm very sensitive to it and I suppose
that's just a byproduct of writing and
editing all the time but yeah take the
extra 10 seconds to look at anything
that's under underlined is a misspelling
what is your most frequently played
music right now on on your phone or
otherwise not that you haven't recorded
yourself yeah I don't listen to my stuff
a lot unless I'm like you know
practicing something or trying to you
know we have some activity that requires
getting into our stuff
I am listening Simon there's two
playlists I have and they're both
actually in my I'm on Spotify and on
beats under my name so if you want to
check out some of the stuff I'm
listening to there's a lot more than
this one batch of music that I'm
listening a lot to is some heavier rock
stuff which you know Tim you're a fan of
the there's not a lot I feel like right
now you know this was part of the
inspiration for our new album was that
there is not a lot of super exciting
brand new cutting-edge aggressive music
out there and I do have a playlist of
some stuff which includes band that
Frank Turner who's like a folk singer
did a hardcore band called Mongol horde
which is amazing such a good album it's
came out a few months ago
there's band called doom riders there's
a band called royal blood judging by the
name you'd think these things are like
really really heavy metal stuff and
they're not there's there's a lot of
melody and some of the songs and it's
just you know really great you know
energetic music awesome alright last
question if you could go back in time
and give some advice to
20 year-old self what would it be 20
year old self helmet by Apple I don't
know
there's there's probably a bit aside
from anything like cheat the system
future style
there's definitely over the course of
our I think it comes back to some one of
the things that we talked about earlier
which is just you know you it's so
important to stick with your gut and if
some voice inside you tells you that
something is the right thing to do the
right way to go about something or the
right thing to make pay attention you
know I've gotten to know Todd Wagner a
little bit and he told me that when he
about investing in a company or a group
of people he always asks them two of the
questions he always asks are would you
be willing to quit your job for this
idea and would you be willing to put all
of your own money behind this idea
mm-hmm and those are questions designed
to say like do you believe in yourself
do you believe in your thing enough is
this an idea for you or is this an idea
because you think someone else will like
it right and if you believe in it to the
point where you put yourself on the line
then that's a good measure of how
important it is to you and how much you
believe in it definitely it's so true I
mean just for those people listening and
at least for me also if if you scratch
your own itch and create something for
yourself the thing that you've been
looking for it you'll always have an
audience of one and that's more than I
can say for a lot of folks you kind of
focus on the outcome and and miss that
because you'll have to live with
whatever you put out if you put
something out Mike this is this has been
a blast
where can people find out more about you
what you're up to and so on
Wilkin Park is obviously on Lincoln Park
calm it's Li nkn PA RK com any social
media Instagram Facebook Twitter
whatever we are we are available under
the same name I am Mike Shinoda calm and
you can find me under that name on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook as well
beautiful Mike I'll let you get to your
music but keep putting out great stuff
look forward to hanging again soon
hopefully next time I'm in down south in
LA yeah thanks man cool awesome thanks
buddy I'll let you get to it I really
appreciate it if you want more of the
Tim Ferriss show you can subscribe to
the podcast on itunes or go to for our
blog com where you'll find an
award-winning blog tons of audio and
video interview stories with people like
Warren Buffett and Mike Shinoda from
Lincoln Park the books plus much much
more
follow tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or on facebook at
facebook.com slash Tim Ferriss until
next time thanks for listening
you